[Music]
how do you know when a player has made
it is it once they've won a major is
that once they've earned the respect of
their peers or is that once they become
the subject of a meme once the community
starts to see them as something other
than just an incredible talent because
if that's the case look no further than
Jame from a vanguard he's made it the
only way he knows how
let's hear it right now for your second
semifinalist a bad ghor it would be an
understatement to call James style of
counter-strike
unorthodox he's calm cool and collected
until he's not left alone by the time
he's gonna run out he's even gonna die
it actually dies after time runs out he
shifts between these bursts of
aggressive activity and safe movement
and often carries his off into the next
round and because James switches between
these Styles you left both confused and
excited when watching him play on one
hand Janne plays really well in a
team-based system powered of how on
considering the situation to get a frag
like that but then came alone in the
middle of mid 11 HP and I think we know
what time it is there's game time
Buster's we finished off all on Jim at
UK 47 in hand and he's nowhere to be
seen in the action No so the save streak
begins here it is
now Jame time is all-encompassing it's
the moments where you wonder does he
understand what's going on right now
both players all the bulbs not here for
big one on tap and that shoot beer at
least a player into the open jim has no
pictus they're just gonna defuse it and
there we go the blue easy as it comes
Jim just looks to steam it like what the
hell did was I it was I meant to go out
there
but James time is also why we love
counter-strike and it's what makes the
majors so much fun to watch this
talented Jesus look-alike came out of
nowhere
and stole our hearts through his
unabashed ability to be himself I think
Jamie is the second coming of Jesus and
he
we'll save my victims sorry chat sorry
the gun saving the calm personality and
the awkward style of play combines for
an incredible experience that get this
even earned an entry in urban dictionary
while the meme is hilarious there is a
method to James madness if you only have
to spend 47 50 a few times per game
instead of saying I don't know six or
seven because you keep getting picked
off at long a yeah you're gonna save
some cash but even when he does embrace
the chaotic fury of CS he stays cool
James licks heads with the quiet
demeanor of someone sitting in an office
cubicle filling out reports and kickin
flash Dignitas get the one killer took a
little bit too long with a grenade oh it
could be beautiful Jane taking down two
and even trying through the smoke that's
a bold move his abilities with the Opera
at full display during the Berlin major
he sees the bomb towards main so it can
be a full rotation for a trend another
tank around the e box but it's still
alive not a problem 11 seconds now two
versus Friederich grenade to stop them
they've gotta find a fried so you'd want
for shame he can't go to the pistol the
bombs being planted Ethan looking over
the top and now it's just that pistol do
the job chamber the three Cade what was
so cool about Jame in Berlin was that it
felt like his tournament his arrival on
a scene looking for something new
something to adopt as their own there's
a bit of a I'm just happy to be here
vibe sure but make no mistake Jamie
knows how good he is and he will let you
know given the opportunity well they got
destroyed by a straw in the finals a
vanguard Jame put the world on notice
the Vanguard the run they have had here
Shawn we set it in the pre-match I think
it's if they bodes well to say it one
more time has been a turnaround and an
evolution I love this word for a matter
you have to yo tip your hat to them they
showed up every time when it mattered
and it looks like it wasn't a fluke they
followed up the major with a win at
blast pro series moscow where james top
fragged across all three maps in the
finals jade the steady hand with the AWP
Jerry
takes long to chest
scout shop here
the major finals they couldn't win now
sadly witness an impressive team we
don't know a ton about Jane and he's
still a relatively fresh face on the
international stage he's made it because
he's talented of course but he's also
made it because of us a community that
sees itself in him every time he takes
the stage we'll be right there with them
ready for game time thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages